[Music]
bonus alert what's up guys I'm Zach
grandma and I was Andrews campaign
manager and now the co-host of our
weekly podcast yang speaks and welcome
back every once in awhile in between our
Monday episodes we're just gonna throw
in a bonus episode midweek and this week
we've got the one and only crystal ball
crystal ball is just a badass she's the
host of the show rising on YouTube which
you guys should check it out she's also
got a really fascinating background
because she worked for MSNBC before this
and has run for Congress in her own
right
so crystal and Andrew you talked about a
whole bunch of fascinating topics they
talked about the future of the
progressive movement now that joe
biden's are presumptive nominee they
also talked about what the heck it's
like to run for Congress for the first
time but the most important thing they
talk about something I'm extremely
passionate about the yang media blackout
so if you were following the 2020 race
at all you saw that Andrew yang at the
least amount of speaking time on every
single debate stage and he had some of
the least mentions and coverage in the
entire race so with crystal hurt Andrew
go inside what we call the belly of the
beast what it was like working on MSNBC
and what incentives are there why does
it can it like Andrew yang get no
coverage so the fascinating conversation
to learn how the world works
learn how mainstream media works I hope
you guys enjoy so tuning now and also
tune in on Monday we're back at it thank
you guys
[Music]
hello everyone and just want to welcome
the incredible crystal ball to yank
speeds crystal yang it's give you a
round of applause oh my gosh I have I
have known admired crystal from before
the campaign really got going where she
was an advocate for universal basic
income and one of the first things I did
was try and track down before I read to
be like yay I'm gonna run for president
on ubi you know let's do this thing so
crystal welcome thank you thank you yeah
it's great to be on Congrats I'm very
excited about this new venture in
direction and yet people don't realize
even before that we had met when I was
at MSNBC and you were a guest on the
cycle when you're with venture for
America and we'd kind of kept in touch
so so we are longtime friends here yeah
I remember that I remember really liking
you even from our MSNBC interview I'm
just thinking like wow she really has
her [ __ ] together
and then I saw your background - you're
like a trained CPA you ran for Congress
and that alone must have been an
incredible set of experiences because I
feel like for you and at the time you
you were I'm sure one of the younger
candidates yeah when I first started
running I was actually 27 it was the
2010 this is the year of the tea party
great time to be running as a
progressive in a rural Virginia district
but you know it was one of these
situations which you could probably
relate to I mean running for Congress is
nothing like running for president but
in terms of sort of jumping in headfirst
I had never worked on a campaign I had
been political in the sense of like
ordinary engaged citizen and I think
like a lot of people in this political
moment I had a kind of awakening then
when I felt called to get more involved
than I have ever conceived of before and
it was actually my husband who you've
also met who was like look at this guy
who's representing your congressional
district this guy's lame you'd be better
than him you should just run for
Congress like you care about these
issues
it's just a lot of the things that you
know that animates you that animates me
the corruption that runs so much of our
politics the problem of money in
politics the way that's infected both
parties like those were the animating
issues for me jumping off and so he kept
at it and eventually it was like you
know what the hell what's the worst
thing that can happen I run and I lose
life goes on and in fact I didn't run
and I did lose and life did in fact as
I'm sure you may be discovering as we
speak I too ran and lost and life has
continued there are some lessons here
because though we could impart to
everyone who's considering running you
will still be alive the day after the
race even if you lose well into and not
eat and not just that and to be serious
for a moment like I think it's obvious
to people watching what you accomplished
in your campaign and especially now
we're universal basic income is like on
the tip of everyone's tongue it's become
a bipartisan you know bipartisan
advocacy for a sort of modified
temporary universal basic income but you
know when you started we looked at the
polls to the extent that people even
knew what that was they were like no
needle so much in your campaign and not
in a strictly partisan way so it's not
like just oh you ran and you lost and
life goes on it's like you ran in you
lost but that doesn't mean that you
didn't accomplish anything and in my own
way - with my campaign obviously
congressional campaign much smaller
scale and like an obscure rural district
very long odds I got absolutely crushed
all those things and yet what I wanted
was the ability to raise the issues that
I cared about that I thought were
important to the country like I wanted
the platform and the voice to be able to
do that I didn't get that by becoming a
member of Congress but I did get it in a
different sort of way so you know it's
it's funny how sometimes you asked for a
thing and you get it just not nearly in
the format that you expected well good
for John encouraging you to run back
then being like yeah you'd be better
than this person which I'm sure you
would have been so can you describe what
it's like to run for Congress
a 27 year old newcomer to politics a
woman in rural Virginia it was very very
scary for me and one of the things
people might be surprised to learn
although actually I don't think it's
that uncommon for media people is I'm uh
sort of naturally more introverted
person and so to put myself out there
like we're a CPA it means you disagree
with numbers a that appeals to me like
being with the spreadsheet is a
appealing thing to me rather than human
beings so you know not only to put
myself out there just in front of people
but also to have the courage to raise my
hand and be like I think I should be the
one like I think you should vote for me
I think I would be the person out of
your available choices who invest our
presented district that was to me very
very scary and I was a young mom at that
point I had now I have three at that
time I had one just very little she's
just a toddler at the time my oldest now
Ella and I remember taking her to an
event a women's event in Virginia for
democratic women candidates and the
signup sheet you're supposed to put down
like normal sign-up sheet this is funny
how I remember all these details this is
how like painful it was for me your name
and if you were running for office
you're supposed to like check a box and
write down what you were running for
it's like paralyzed because it was so US
Congress I was like oh my god like do I
put on US Congress or put down House of
Representatives you're like what's the
right thing that I should put down here
where people aren't gonna think I'm
stupid and don't know what I'm doing so
I add an eyes over that I get in the
room I'm sweating nervous and the child
is misbehaving which makes me feel even
more awkward and she's just being a
normal toddler but you know I'm just
like stressed down about all this stuff
and then the time comes during their
talk with their like raise your hand if
you're running for office and I
literally didn't do it I mean this was
one of the first events what about for
women running as Democrats for office
and I was too afraid and
moment to do it but I kept going I kept
pushing I got I found my voice I found
like you know an enthusiastic base of
support it was a brutal year Tea Party
wave all of that I mean seeing all of
that up close and what has led to now
was also just you know incredibly
formative but ultimately what I came to
was realizing that I was so fixated on
like me my performance how am i doing
what are people thinking of me that this
really wasn't actually about me yes I'm
the person on the ballet yes all of that
but what I focused on the people in the
room and what they needed and what they
weren't getting then suddenly that took
a lot of the the fear out of it and it
made it you know made it a lot easier
and I think it was also more you know
more successful ultimately and more
impactful because of that focus on that
that's tremendous crystal I remember how
awkward it was telling people I was
running for president for a while what
they were like president of you know
like your co-op board so I remember all
of these internal hurdles you have to
overcome yeah and then just saying it to
someone and having a straight face and
then have them receive it in a
particular way I'm sure for you it was a
real journey over a number of weeks and
months where you'd say I'm running to be
your congressperson and then I go over
time it would it would actually become
natural and feel like you yeah I mean I
don't know that it ever really felt a
hundred percent natural but and of
course you know you had your own like
stereotypes that you were overcoming as
an asian-american I had stereotypes that
I was overcoming I had people tell me
like the only thing you should be
running for is after your children who
said stuff like that to me but you know
you sort of come to a place and a peace
with it and ultimately you know I feel
that decision point for me
obviously of deciding to step off the
path that I was on the CPA path the
spreadsheet path now there's nothing
wrong with that that it's a good path I
don't want to step into into public life
in that way and say like I'm planning my
flag in the ground and I'm gonna do what
I can to try to lift my voice to these
things that I think matter that was
obviously a real pivot point in my life
and one that I am you know tremendously
proud of taking in spite of the fact
that you know still today like we were
talking before we came on air like
people are being mean to be on Twitter
and I'm still like oh it's hard like how
hard are people's lives out there if
you're not willing to step out get
uncomfortable take that incoming then
what are you actually willing to do well
crystal there are a lot of people right
now we're trying to make changes in
their communities and I feel like your
journeys such like an awesome example
for so many like if you had guidance for
someone who's thinking some of the same
thoughts you were thinking when you were
27 about trying to do something positive
in their community what they'd have to
go through let's say it's a woman who
like isn't necessarily going to get the
kind of reception or support that you
know you might hope for like what kind
of guidance would you have for them you
know one of the things that has been a
struggle for me and I don't know that
this is for everyone but I think there's
a lot of cultural programming in America
for women to like be the good girl right
you get a lot of praise for like doing
the right thing and following the rules
and deferring to others and sharing and
playing nicely like those things are all
reinforced continuously you know for
little girls in particular coming up in
America and probably even more so you
know young girls of color and so for me
one of the it's stupid but like one of
the psychological barriers I've had to
overcome is being willing to people you
know to break some eggs for people to
think that I'm divisive or controversial
because if you're going to get anything
to if you are going to change the status
quo right say
every American should get $1,000
regardless of income like done that's a
controversial thing and there are gonna
be people who don't like you for who say
means things about you for who have a
financial interest in keeping things the
way that they are who want to smear and
dismiss you and so if you have any sort
of critique that is going to alter the
status quo you have to be prepared that
you're not gonna be the good girl you're
not gonna get the gold star you're not
always gonna get the pat on the head but
for the people whose lives you're
changing you will be a hero and it's a
small price to pay ultimately it's like
a psychological price it's it's really
such a small price to have to bear but
for me that's been something I've really
had to check within myself that desire
to like pull back and say oh maybe I'm
going too far maybe I'm pushing too hard
and I think I suspect that that's the
case in particular for a lot of women I
bet you're right certainly I had a note
on my phone just this is sort of a fun
anecdote where it just says just
remember that to the vast majority of
Americans you are the magical Asian man
who wants to give everyone money I was
like whatever that way anyway so another
sort of funny comparison is that I went
to this Asian American and politics
event early on in my race in DC and
absolutely no one like was clamoring to
support the Adrienne campaign at that
event it was like yeah it was more like
who what what is going on and this is
after I declared so just that reminds me
of like you know when you're talking
about being in the room with the women
who are running for office the Democrat
and not raising your hand like it's it's
not easy yeah
well do you mind can I turn the tables a
little bit I mean what was kind of like
the what was the toughest moment of your
campaign what was that low point where
you had to reach for those sort of like
you know the note
that that bolsters you or your family or
whatever the things are that keep you
whole insane there were a lot of tough
moments on the campaign I think after
the first debate was like a struggle
because I didn't get much airtime and
there was a sense I had let a lot of
people down and so from so that point
was like a gut check there were other
tough points around just being on the
road a lot and being away from family
for a while when things were not going
well and you're just like what the [ __ ]
am i doing like you know or be early on
in the campaign we were scratching and
clawing for every bit of resources and I
would call friends of mine and be like
hey can you just donate two thousand
dollars to my campaign people that two
thousand dollars is not that big a deal
to and they would not do it honestly
they would or they they would and like
that stuff were just like oh my gosh man
like you know we've been friends for
years this is not anything that should
be that big a deal like at least in my
world like a situation was reversed I
think I'd do it without much thought
particularly if you called me if you
called me then I'd be like oh my gosh
you're calling me like I really should
have done this already but like people
just wouldn't do it
you know like it I had that say and it
surprises you because on the one hand
people you really think you're gonna be
able to count on or like no I'm not
there for you and then people who you're
barely in touch with right who have been
like barely a part of your life I mean
for me I'd tell you very specifically
there's like this high school philosophy
teacher you know I took one year of
philosophy with him in high school
and I never even would have thought to
reach out to him to ask for me this is
not a wealthy individual and yet every
time I sent out a fundraising
solicitation he would come in with like
five hundred dollars and you know those
people show up as well so it really
really reveals the sort of I don't want
to say the character because I don't
want to make it like a character flaw
issue but it really shows you who's
gonna be there personally for you in
your life well what I've said is that
when you do something that's real
important to you whether it start a
business or run for office you make some
friends and you lose some friends yeah I
you know that that's happened every
single time for me and you know you just
have to like try and shrug and move on
but there are some real like scars and
like wounds where you're just like wow I
thought that if there's anyone I could
have counted on it's you and it turns
out that is not the case yeah so there
were certainly ups and downs to the
campaign but one of the things that we
tried to be as we tried to be the
positive a few civ because it seemed
like politics generally it was such a
slog that you know like if if you could
avoid the negativity I thought that
would be a massive advantage I think
that that really came through to people
because well you had this sort of dire
assessment of the state of America you
had this you know one of my boy was I
wrong hi crystal great when you're
talking about things are going perfect
now one of my critiques of the
Democratic Party that I think you share
is that you know there's a lot of
contempt frankly that comes from some
parts of the party towards some types of
people in the country especially you
know in rural areas or people who voted
for Donald Trump like there's just when
I was living in Kentucky state that I
really you know really really loved and
find interesting that people are
wonderful and you know would would be
happy to make my home there again if
given the chance and I would their
politics are very interesting I would
send out things that were going on in
Kentucky people losing health care
right-to-work being passed terrible for
working people and I would get back
these messages that are like well screw
them they voted for Trump I'm just like
where did we like I didn't sign up to
belong to a group of people who are
gonna pick and choose who is healthcare
right and who has the who they have
compassion for right I mean this is the
same group of people that rightly in my
view would have lots of compassion for
you know people who are incarcerated who
like broke the law who messed
but they believe they deserve a second
chance I believe that too but you're
gonna show them mercy and compassion but
for this other group because you don't
like the way they voted or you think
that they're not you know evolved enough
on different issues you're gonna just
write them off and have complete
contempt for an entire state based on
that I'm not aligned
yeah and that was one of the things that
I really admired about your campaign as
I felt like that message of you know
we've got some problems in this country
but in terms of the people like just
fundamental sort of respect and value of
the people of the country which doesn't
sound like a radical notion but I fear
is a bit of a radical notion I thought
that was one of the most important and
frankly most courageous parts of your
campaign
well thank you for characterizing it as
courageous it was just to me the common
sense straight for a natural thing to do
but I remember being attacked as like a
right winger when i retweeted a New York
Times article about opiate death rates
in predominantly rural white parts of
the country that it was literally a New
York Times article about these death
rates and then people were like oh this
is some kind of you know like appeal to
conservatives alright I was like why
would an article about opiate death
rates it were white parts of the country
somehow only matter to a certain segment
of Americans like you know that would
matter to everyone in my mind and so
that there were some things that I
frankly just learned through the process
that would never have occurred to me ya
know I remember in early days there was
this whole thing going on about how your
support was all coming from white
nationalists and that was a you know a
whole theme of the early days and look
you see that consistently with kind of
you know outside the establishment
movement there's an attempt to just like
dismiss them as you know oh there those
people are all you don't wanna be
associated with those people they're all
white now they're all have these
problematic views or whatever tactical
business
and they tried that very much with you
yeah I mean I know I don't know if it
was delivered it was very confusing
though from my perspective where did
this come from so you run for Congress
lose and then MSNBC reaches out and says
like hey do you want to come on air like
what was that that conversation yeah
so I mean I assume you know this story
but I don't know if you know this story
so at the end of my campaign they're
these stupid party photos that are
released on a right-wing blog in
Virginia and they're like you know I
mean I'm I'm of age I'm fully clothed
like but they're sort of you know
sexually provocative right and so this
thing takes off like wildfire now I've
got this weird name I'm young like right
I mean it just all feeds into this
stupid cable news feeding frenzy and so
I this is a kind of an interesting part
of it most of the advice I got from the
sort of political consultant types was
just don't say anything I hope it goes
away right well it was not going on I
mean I was like the third most googled
person the world's so stupid and if you
looked at the photos at this point you
know it's so mild in comparison to the
politics that we have now but anyway so
I decided to go on cable news and defend
myself and say like what for you crystal
sexist [ __ ] if it was a man you
wouldn't care in fact Scott Brown and if
you remember this had run that same
cycle and he'd like pose nude and the
media narrative around that was oh he's
like he's a beefcake this is like part
of his appeal but with me I was like a
ho-bag who shouldn't be trusted right so
I went on I defended myself I called it
on as a double standard as a bunch of
sexist [ __ ] which it was and the
funny thing and this comes back to like
getting the thing that you want just not
in the package that you expected was
that that very thing which had been done
to try to destroy me
actually gave me that platform and so
you know I was a long shot congressional
candidate who got her butt kicked I
would never have gotten any media
attention but for that and so after the
election some of the shows that had had
me on asked me to come back just to talk
about like let's talk about women in the
midterms and then I did okay with that
and they're like let's talk about you
know this political issue in general and
that just sort of snowballed and I shout
out to the you know the two people in
particular who put me on the most in
those early days I don't know if you
remember know Dylan Ratigan who'd been
at at CNBC and then MSNBC and who was
one of the you know the people who
really understood that the financial
collapse somebody I still really like
and trust and then megyn kelly who of
course very independent-minded
over at fox and so those were the two
people who started having me on and it
just sort of snowballed from there so
it's funny how these things work out
sometimes Andrew Wow
so then when MSNBC offered the job like
that must have been a very big lifestyle
shift for you because of that but you
know to that point you'd been living in
Virginia you you know had one daughter
had you had your second child at this
point no I had him while I was at MSNBC
yeah so I mean that must have been a
very big lifestyle switch did you
commute or did you guys move to New York
no we moved to New York and in fact we
moved to New York
even before I got the show when they
just made me a contributor which is like
you know you're like a you know a fancy
contributor at CNN but I was like a
low-level like yeah whatever we may put
you on the air if we feel like it
contributor at MSNBC but we kind of
decided to throw in with that path and
see what happens so we had already moved
to New York and yeah it was like the
most exciting thing I could imagine to
have that show and I had some I got to
work with some you know some great
co-hosts I got to work with my executive
producer who had been actually Dylan
Ratigan executive producer but before
that he's like a he's like a cable news
legend frankly he was a he was the EP of
the Today Show executive producer The
Today Show he he hired Matt and Katie he
built that outdoor plaza so he is still
my like TV mentor and it was
an incredible experience to get to work
with him and at the same time you know
you get a real education in just the
sort of sausage-making of the cable news
world which has been I think part of the
the that inner understanding is part of
what I've brought now to rising that I
think a lot of our oh yes respond to
yeah I mean that's there are a lot of
people have kind of bit on the inside
but are willing to critique it because
it's look it's hard these you know you
get to know these people who become your
friends you don't want to like be mean
to them but at the same time there are
obviously a lot of as you know blind
spots and failures in coverage and I
would say in particular sort of class
blind spots and blind spots for any any
anti-establishment candidate you know
desire to sort of minimize then and
minimize their approach because what it
means for for upsetting your access or
the status quo that sort of gives you
your station there and so I think that
perspective has been part of what people
have responded to on rising I agreed but
I want to hear more about your time at
MSNBC as you were there for how many
years cameras I think it's five now
that's significant so you were deep in
and how did that what was like the peak
of that relationship and then how did it
end such a funny it's such a funny story
so partly I wasn't necessarily exactly
politically simpatico 2015 2016 primary
started to come into view I did a
monologue in early I want to say it was
2014 it was before Hillary Clinton had
even officially declared and I did this
monologue that was like look I have
respect for Secretary Clinton and what
she's accomplished and her intellect but
this is a terrible candidate right now
like she's so tied in with the
establishment she
so tied in with Wall Street with these
you know she sat on the board of Walmart
she gave these speeches and made all
this money like please Hillary don't run
because if you do it's gonna freeze the
field we're gonna have very limited
options and you are the wrong candidate
for the moment and that
has become obvious in retrospect in fact
frankly a lot of that was obvious at the
time but nobody had releases that it was
it was not that obvious at the time and
certainly was not a popular opinion and
no one had been willing to say it on
like mainstream airwaves
so the Clinton folks did not appreciate
that perspective and they apparently you
know reached out to the president of the
network and then look I wasn't censored
nobody told me I couldn't say what I
wanted to say ever right but I was told
that any of my future commentary about
Hillary Clinton had to be you know
vetted by like the president of the
network had to sign off on it and look
and this is part of understanding how
this medium works it's not that there's
a directive that comes down and says you
will support Hillary Clinton but you're
gonna be subject you know what's gonna
win you praise and what's gonna like
make your life more difficult basically
and I'm a human being I'm sure that I
changed some of you know how hard I went
or how aggressive I was her off and I
was willing to say it because I knew
there was that added level of scrutiny
but ultimately you know there was a big
there was a new NBC News president Andy
lack who came in and it's a funny
backstory because you remember Brian
Williams was in trouble he'd lied about
things and they were trying to figure
out they pulled him off the air but here
he is this like quarterback player with
us big you know multi-million dollar
contract and then try to figure out what
to do and so they basically bring in
Andy Lac who was an old friend of Brian
Williams to figure out what to do and
the decision was we're going to clear
out all of the opinion on daytime MSNBC
so that Brian can come in as like a
breaking news anchor but it would be
uncomfortable for him to have to come in
during like these opinion hours so we're
gonna fill out the line
with NBC News journalists and this was
like this brief moment before Trump got
elected when you know after Trump got
elected all of the opinion hours are
what skyrocketed in the ratings and so
they sort of a ban in that direction but
it's a tie that time the idea was we got
to get rid of all these like people with
opinions and put in the NBC News people
and so I was part of that culling where
our show was canceled Alex Wagner Ronan
Farrow joy Reid had a daytime show that
she lost then she ultimately ends up on
the weekends ed Schultz was let go in a
similar time frame there was just like a
wholesale cleaning out to the point it
really I think wasn't you know personal
so to speak I never really met Andy lack
before that decision was made but I
think the fact that it was so impersonal
made it harder for me to take because it
was like it was like the good girl thing
again like I did everything that you've
been there for almost five years you
know I mean there I'd been like the team
player whenever they needed me to I was
there like I raised my hands for all
that - like all the feedback I got was I
was doing well and the cycle had some of
the best ratings among young viewers
which was supposed to be like an
important metric and aunt like I felt I
did it all right and I still got
cancelled and that was like that was a
hard thing psychologically for me to
deal with yeah I'd be hard for anyone I
mean again you're there for five years
you're putting your heart and soul into
something and then it gets axed yes but
you know again like I'm grateful for
that because now with what I where I am
at this point first of all I took the
time after I was NBC to have another
child which obviously is a great
blessing and gift that I'm very grateful
for but also like I have so much more
freedom in what I do now I'm so much
more of a free person frankly and I
wouldn't trade that for anything I would
I would never want to go back to that
role that I had even though it was so
painful at the time to lose so you know
I'm I'm grateful to them because I I
think
I think it all worked out I guess it's
what I'm trying to say and so I
appreciate that moment in the life in my
life even though it was kind of hard to
take at the time well I would say so I
mean you you are off to the races now
with the rising and the entire the book
which I have directly behind me nice
here it is the populist guide to 2020 by
crystal and her co-host and co-author
Sagar and Yeti did I get Tigers last
name right you nailed it you nailed both
of them works so yeah I mean you're now
this unfettered independent voice and
people really sense it and respond to it
I can't tell you how many times people
would send me your monologues or video
clips from your show and I think what's
wild is I feel like you're now this
hybrid between like it just off and this
is meant as a compliment but just like
as like a full-on independent voice like
podcaster and a media company or like
this kind of hybrid where it feels like
you're melding like a personal point of
view with institutional weight yeah I
think that is exactly right and I don't
know that there's anyone else who's
quite in this Lane and my own theory in
terms of sort of wielding power and
leverage within the media I think like
an activist here is the most powerful
conversation is to have a combination of
real grassroots following Plus elite
awareness right and you know this is
this is partly the model of your
campaign to like you developed this
grassroots following took forever for
elite media to actually take you
seriously at all
Bernie Sanders in 2016 had the same
thing like the crowds were there than
enthusiastically like energy for this
movement and these ideas and it took
forever for elite media to take it
seriously and to me that melting when
you can have some foot into the kind of
elite world where they they know that
you're there
they're paying attention on what you're
doing you're having some ability to
influence that conversation plus a real
grassroots following is like the magic
formula and I'm not saying that we've
like achieve that but that's kind of
that's kind of ultimately the goal and
you know one of the things that I this
is just an essentially an accident I
mean some of these things were
intentional and some of them we just
sort of stumbled into you know the fact
that we have this very cable news
looking set right which is different
from most other YouTube programs it's
funny how those sort of visual
indicators are really important to
people because if they have this more
anti-establishment or populist viewpoint
it's not represented in mainstream first
of all it's just very validating to them
to see someone who at least looks
mainstream having a similar perspective
and like validating those ideas but
we've also had so many viewers tell us
that what they love is that they can
take our segments and send them to a
brother-sister mom and friend whoever
who doesn't necessarily share their
politics who's mostly watching sort of
mainstream news and they won't reject it
out of hand because it has the right
look yeah it looks familiar yeah so
they'll at least like listen to it with
a more open mind because it looks like
something that they have watched before
so like I said that was sort of I didn't
see that in advance as being an
important part of it but it has ended up
being a significant part of sort of the
innovation of rising I think I like it
you're like a wolf in sheep's clothing
just like throw that set on it then you
can say whatever you want
[Music]
so we're just noted that MSNBC didn't
exactly shine a spotlight on Bernie you
know during his campaign ahead of 2016
do you have any perspective on that like
what why why does it seem like the folks
in certain environments don't exactly
embrace the opportunity to talk about
the Bernese of the world I think there
are a lot of reasons and again I don't
think sometimes it is as blatant as like
you are not going to cover this person
positively like sometimes legitimately
is that blatant but mostly it's more
these sort of sort of incentive
structures and blind spots that exist I
think one of the big blind spots that
exists throughout the elite news media
or legacy news media or whatever you
want to call it has to do with class
right and this makes sense these are
mostly upper class people they're mostly
surrounded with other upper class people
at this point there's so little local
journalism that you don't have as many
people coming from like you know the
scrappy beat in Scranton or wherever
there's just you know for example and I
I say this with love because I genuinely
love all the co-hosts I had at the cycle
I started the cycle I was the only
person on a four co-hosts who wasn't
from Massachusetts so there's a little
bit of like a monoculture that creates
some natural blind spots so if you have
a movement whether it's Donald Trump's
movement where you know he has a truly
devoted white working-class base that
you know people in news media just they
just didn't know or see these folks so
they're easy to ignore Bernie Sanders
has a disproportionately young and
working-class base so there's just sort
of a natural tendency to dismiss what
you don't have personal experience with
and don't personally understand so I
think that
part of it I think another part of it is
the way that political journalism works
is you're very dependent for your
promotions and your own sort of
visibility and Buzz and all of those
things that come with that on access to
you know the the politicians in this
town and so it becomes very
uncomfortable to challenge or go against
those politicians or to embrace someone
who poses a threat to them right so
Bernie Sanders obviously whatever you
think of them posed a threat to the sort
of establishment of the Democratic Party
in this town that means all the
consultants who depend on the gig flow
that means all of the cable news pundits
whose contracts depend on access to that
structure right
that means donors who love to have their
egos stroked with those phone calls and
get to show up at the White House
Christmas party and all that stuff right
Bernie was legitimately a threat to that
established order and so it was more it
was uncomfortable for a lot of
mainstream journalists who depended on
access to that world to challenge that
world and to have an open mind I think
about the Sanders movement and again
these things are like I don't want to
make it sound like it's some nefarious
plot these are natural human instincts
to give like in group thinking and you
know the people you're surrounded with
and the things that you're comfortable
with like all of that is very natural
but because you have this kind of eat
monoculture within the news it adds up
to very skewed coverage when you're
talking about candidates who don't fit
their mold who or who come from outside
of the establishment to me a natural
move if you were that organization would
just look up and say okay I guess we
should try and hire someone with a
different background outlook perspective
and make sure that we're covering like a
set of issues or candidates or regions
that we're not seeing right now but it
doesn't seem like
many organizations really have that kind
of process of soul-searching I write it
well and that's where the you know
that's where the bottom line comes into
play because ultimately most of these
news outlets The Times The Post MSNBC
CNN most of their viewership is a sort
of affluent white liberal viewership so
in a sense you know these are these are
capitalistic organizations they're they
are looking out for their own interests
their own bottom line they have a
consumer in mind this is never
explicitly stated of course but it's
true
they have a particular customer that's
gonna buy New York Times subscriptions
that's gonna sign up for the Washington
Post all that stuff and so that's who
they're gonna cater to mostly in cities
mostly white mostly affluent mostly
liberal and so that's also part of this
whole package is that there isn't really
an incentive to bring in those other
perspectives and try to play to other
regions of the country because that
isn't the customer base that they're
looking for that their advertisers are
expecting to want to reach yeah it that
makes sense given that at this point
everything's just flowing towards the
almighty dollar and wherever the dollars
are where the advertising dollars are
that's where your organization's going
ahead and you did something I really
admired which is you tried to elevate
non-traditional candidates out in
different parts of the country you're
the reason why I became a Richard Oh
Giada fanboy and supporter and became
friends with Richard we ended up hiring
several people from his campaign staff
in West Virginia so if you want to talk
about some of the work you've done to
try and address the problems that you
and I are describing right now yeah well
it goes back to what we were saying
about some elements of the Democratic
Party having contempt for certain
regions of the country for you know for
working-class people in particular white
working-class people is you very much
discovered and but I think you know
there's so much class contempt in our
society in general so much looking down
the nose so much you know condescension
towards working-class people who we're
discovering now more than ever I mean
these are the they're essential workers
today of course but they're always
essential words these literally the
people who make our country run like
we're completely dependent they're gonna
be yeah they're gonna be a lot of people
in urban locations right now that are
going to absolutely freak out if there
is a supply chain disruption out of
Kansas Nebraska Iowa you know with if
meatpacking workers and truck drivers
like decide not to do what what they're
supposed to do like you know we're gonna
find out just who is important very
quickly and there are people right now
that are worried about that happening
you are 1,000% correct
I don't know if you followed this Purdue
chicken processing plan and bleed down
in rural Georgia and the workers were
protesting because they weren't getting
hazard pay they didn't have safety
protective equipment and when the
workers was like we are out here risking
our lives for chicken right and that's
that's like to me it's so telling and
it's also kind of a central theme of
your campaign like just respecting
people's humanity treating their lives
as more important than having this
Michelle fully stocked at all times with
Purdue chicken nuggets I mean it's
really it's really that basic and so one
of the things that I believe profoundly
in is representation of working-class
people in the halls of power not in like
a focus group or in a poll or like come
on crystal all we have to do is find out
what magic words to say to them and
write or like as you know as humans sort
of props but you know behind a
politician who speaking know I think
working-class people should have power
like actually like be the ones holding
power because they are the ones not just
today but always on the front lines in
our economy and just as representation
matters for diverse communities it
matters that you have people who are our
servers and our waitstaff and our
delivery workers and people working
warehouses are like what you mentioned
Richard oh Jetta
was a veteran who served our country
like it matters to have those people not
just being pandered too but actually
having power and I believed in my you
know I'm sort of becoming less hopeful
about the Democratic Party at this point
moves were being honest but I really
think that one of the ways that the
Democratic Party could bridge this
divide that has been artificially
inserted between the white working-class
and the black and brown working-class is
by having more voices that are
themselves working-class and so you
don't have that sort of cultural barrier
of people like you know I mean I saw the
the Democratic Congressional Campaign
Committee supporting these like
lobbyists who barely lived in the
district and they come back and they get
consultant to tell them how to talk to
people in their own hometown it's like
what are you doing why not find people
who understand their community who talk
like their communities share like aren't
just viewing this resin outsider they
actually share in the struggles of that
community like why not try to elevate
those individuals and see what happens
in terms of how they wield power and who
they ultimately represent so Richard is
a great example of that JD Schulten who
was running a guy in Iowa he's I mean
just a just a great guy right right JD
Jesse other day just continued if there
are other people like JD and Richard and
running against a particularly odious
member of Congress Steve King yeah the
Kings that guy who literally even the
Republicans kicked him out because he
got a little too blatantly racist yeah
he's from Iowa okay which was not a part
of the Confederacy and he still had a
confederate flag on his in his office I
mean this is like what we're talking
about but so people like JD there's
another woman down in North Carolina I
love named Edie Adams she got her start
she's a tee shoes teamster working on
line and you know these I think we need
more of that in the Democratic Party in
particular in politics in general I mean
you just don't a mess those voices
represented so
something that I you know that I believe
in and I've tried to tried to work on
try to highlight some of those facts
well I was so confused where when I
would meet people who were working-class
in different parts of the country and
when I said I was a Democrat they were
like oh no and I was like man you really
hate Democrats around here and I was
like are we supposed to be sticking up
for you the truck driver you the farmer
you the waitress like what like what the
heck has gone wrong for the Democratic
Party we're working-class Americans
don't think it's their party in a lot of
the country like that that to me is like
the central theme that we seem to be
missing it's it's a it truly for me is
heartbreaking because I've always seen
myself as a Democrat and I've always
believed that the Democratic Party was
the party of the working class but you
know this is this is frankly it's been
an intentional shift right and it
started with Bill Clinton in the 90s
there was an intentional decision to
orient the party more around sort of you
know white-collar affluent suburban
nights not that there's anything wrong
with those individuals but that's a very
different kind of politics because
you're talking about people economically
who more or less benefit from the status
quo so they're not interested as much in
putting sort of those you know economic
transformational economics at the center
of their political agenda and so that
decision has translated over many years
to where we are now
that you know the the Democratic Party
year after year after year has become
more centered around that demographic
the politics are more representative of
their perspective and then you know for
the black and the brown working-class
it's basically like well you can't vote
for the Republicans because they're too
racist so you're stuck with us and the
Republicans do their own version of that
right they've got like their affluent
interests that they cater to and then to
the white working-class it's like oh
well those Democrats hate you they have
contempt for you so you're stuck with us
and and what happens when you divide the
multiracial working class like that is
you've ended up with two parties that
basically represent affluent interests
and I'm not trying to say like they're
both equivalent or there's no difference
between oh no it's true
course but if you asked you to look at
this response on coronavirus the
economic response I mean every single
senator voted to give four trillion
dollars which is much more than the
media typically reports but they are
leveraging the amount that was in the
bill the Federal Reserve is leveraging
that to give four trillion dollars in
loans to big business the small business
fund that evaporated like that and we
know it would this was entirely
predictable why is there even a cap on
that fund the amount to individuals
pathetic and one-time payment and you've
got millions who are getting kicked out
of their jobs filing for unemployment I
mean these are all choices that were
made not just as inevitable these are
all choices that were made and they are
the byproduct of two parties that have
the interests of the affluent first and
so I think you know the the results of
that could not be more clear than
outrageously in in this moment and with
that small business I mean this just
completely outrages me and you know I'm
sure you know people and I know people
as well who's totally cold they're like
applying and getting no response in
trying to keep their businesses afloat
trying to keep their employees employed
trying to be able to pay their rent you
know for their for their business for
their location and because the
implementation of this program first of
all the dollar amount way too small
why is there a capital second of all the
implementation is left to the banks who
are just so dumb you won't see air
service to their biggest any client of
their is it's got the red carpet and
then if you didn't have a private banker
you were [ __ ] exact that's exactly
right
had they had special concierge service
and all the mom-and-pop small businesses
got screwed and so what are we gonna see
coming out of this crisis rather than
you know the kind of reinvigoration of
small you know small businesses of local
industry of keeping wealth you know
locally in our communities that was one
possible outcome of this crisis and
instead we're gonna have the exact
opposite yes amazon's the Walmarts the
apples of the world they're just gonna
get bigger and bigger and I just was
reading before we started talking
something like a hundred thousand shops
stores are likely to go under as a
result of this and again that was a
choice made in a bipartisan fashion by
both of the parties here
a lot of these jobs are not coming back
it's heartbreaking I see the same things
and to me the best course of action
would be for the government just to be
like look just send us the bill but you
know like eight landlords don't charge
your tenants send us the bill hey like
you baby businesses you have rent send
us the bill we're just gonna pay for it
over this multi month period of time and
then when it's time to reopen then you
can just come back but until then like
we got it and you're right like what is
the purpose even of a cap like it
doesn't make any sense that the you know
when you're talking about trying to
elevate people from different
backgrounds in the leadership it
reminded me of German companies that
have board seats for people who are in
the factory or the manufacturing plant
like you literally have people with high
school with equivalent high school
education but they had a lot of
technical you know apprenticeships and
training but literally like from the the
shop floor to sitting there in the
boardroom being like hey that's a bad
idea it's a good idea and like you know
the decision-making is going to be
entirely different for the fact that
those people are genuinely they're not
just expressing that perspective but
pulling the lever that's the kind of
thing we would need in our government
wholesales like you had people who
actually just said like hey guess what
you know like I've like like my people
are putting their lives on the line for
[ __ ] chicken nuggets and you know
they think they don't have adequate
protection they're getting paid like
chicken scratch probably almost like you
know literally and the rest of it I mean
it's it's infuriating it's heartbreaking
you know like I'm grateful that at least
we've moved the needle on this
conversation where it seems like there's
gonna be an openness and enthusiasm to a
universal basic income that there
because to me it's like tens of millions
of Americans are gonna get money in
their bank accounts they're gonna be
like well that was great and then when
someone says hey you should probably do
that all the time
then people will be like that's probably
an excellent idea but you're right like
we've mishandled this
in so many ways well and that is the
thing is I think part of the reluctance
to do more as then you make people
realize that you could do more that all
of the like how will you pay for it was
all [ __ ] and like oh once you
realize the government could be part of
helping me secure my economic interests
or you know providing health care then
you're not gonna turn around and forget
that that happened and be like okay I'll
go back to working for 725 and killing
myself and not having health insurance
and still not being able to pay my rent
even after the pandemic you're gonna say
oh wait a second government you did this
before we could do this again in normal
times normal talk do that right well I
think part of what like how come we're
not having more of a conversation about
healthcare during a pandemic how come
we're not covering coronavirus treatment
during the pandemic it's because if you
do that then people are gonna so we'll
wait a second if you can cover my
coronavirus treatment how come you're
gonna let me like starve because of any
other illness so I think that's part of
the reluctance frankly to do more is
because then you people start to expect
better I used to tell people on the
trail crystal the biggest lie in
American life is that we don't have the
money that people are just going around
be like oh we're going broke it's like
are you kidding me
you know when push came to shove we
found four trillion for the banks we
found one-and-a-half trillion for the
big companies for stock buybacks and
Americans saw it very clearly just now
it's like when you needed it
2.2 trillion or 2.8 trillion or 4
trillion was there you know like what we
can do much much more for our people but
so many people have essentially been
brainwashed to think that we're broke
and meanwhile we're the wealthiest
Society in the history of the world and
you have a trillion dollar company like
Amazon paying zero in taxes while hiring
another hundred thousand people in the
midst of a pandemic like the the the the
confusion is intentional I mean people
have just been spreading these messages
and hammer
the fact that like oh these people are
trying to pull one over on you meanwhile
like their people's communities are
disintegrating how quickly were they
able to flip the switch and pour tons of
money to support the financial system
like that ours was in place but the
backstop for average Americans for small
businesses still haven't found it I mean
they were able to mobilize to undergird
and provide a safe big you know big
fancy safety net for the financial
system but those mechanisms have not
been designed and are not in place for
average Americans and it tells you where
the true priorities live moments like
that really reveal where the true
priorities lie and what this country is
actually set up to do and who it serves
yes it's socialism for the wealthy and
well-connected and rugged individualism
for the average family that's out there
trying to figure out how the heck to pay
the rent
it's it is very dark and I I remain you
know I'm a very positive guy I mean I
guess you have to be positive to run for
president out of total anonymity most of
it I believe that illusions are dying as
a result of this crisis and that people
will be hungry for a different more
dramatic set of solutions
I certainly hope that we're in position
to be able to make those solutions real
as quickly as possible because the
suffering is unimaginable yeah I I hope
that you're right and I think that you
are I really genuinely do I think the
mask is coming off in a lot of ways in
terms of our priorities and who this
town ultimately serves
[Music]
am I allowed to turn the tables can I
ask you a question yeah mm-hmm so how
are you thinking about you know I was I
was critical of how quickly you jumped
on board with the Biden campaign and
when you endorsed him and all of that
but I'm curious about like how you're
thinking about a potential Biden
administration what are your best hopes
and what are your concerns so I intended
to stay neutral but but then it looked
like Joe was going to be the nominee to
like a 99 percent probability at that
point I said you know what like we need
to try and unify to beat Trump because
he has like this massive head start a
resource advantage the bully pulpit and
all these other things so that was my
thinking and I get along well with Joe
Bernie was an inspiration for me like
you know in my mind to me it was about
trying to put ourselves in the best
position to win and I like I'm in a
position where I think that any extra
day of a trump presidency is is a
disaster and that it like four more
years of this would be would genuinely
be catastrophic I mean heck we're living
it now my best hopes for Biden
administration's that we win and then we
start digging out and solving these
problems and much bigger more dramatic
ways and I personally think the entire
like I'm a moderate I'm a progressive
like I think that stuff's gonna go out
the window in the same way that you saw
things go out the window when Congress
came together to pass the stimulus we're
like you know if you were a fiscal
conservative you were still like yep 2.2
trillion let's do it you know like like
I think that there's going to be a
clarity of need and a practicality in
our approach that's going to make it so
that all things are on the table because
people are dying and it's not just
people are dying directly of the virus
it'll be that people are dying on the
streets in different ways and we're
going to have to become much much more
aggressive about
trying to solve people's problems that
is what I think our best chance is and
so does it concern you because I see Joe
Biden as having been part and parcel of
getting us to the place we are now we're
even
you know before coronavirus working
people were so pushed up against the
wall where you know I 40% of Americans
can't afford a $400 emergency we're
talking about right I mean like all in
the name of like efficiency and
increasing GDP job shipped overseas sure
go ahead with automation displacing
workers and not providing anything you
know any support underneath yeah
obviously like the disastrous war on
drugs that's something you've been
incredibly courageous and calling out
and he was a prime architect of that and
do those things concern you in terms of
how he will actually govern because I
think one of the things that you and I
share and correct me if I'm wrong but I
know you said this on the campaign trail
is that Trump is a symptom right he is a
problem in and of himself but he's also
a symptom of a deep problem and so
that's my concern with a Biden
administration is like he's actually
he's part of erecting the system that
actually enabled a Trump to come to
power and frankly I'm more fearful of
what could come after a Donald Trump as
bad as Trump is you know he's like
incompetent and bumbling and he doesn't
know what he wants and he's like
buffeted and can't he couldn't even get
a question changed on the census and
that's not to undermine the real danger
that he represents but I'm more fearful
about what two four more years of
incrementalism and reinforcing the
status quo that Broadus Trump like what
comes after that I'm optimistic that no
sane administration would be pursuing
incrementalism when you have literally
historic levels of unemployment like the
lowest proportion of Americans working
in history I believe like you'd have to
be very very misguided
you're pursuing incrementalism now I
mean that's what the parties have teamed
up to do in Washington right now while
26 million people are filing for
unemployment now I'm I don't disagree
with the fact that this response has
been like a [ __ ] show and yeah and that
we need to do things differently I think
most people know and I think most people
also know that like I disagree with with
Joe on many of the fronts you just
described another it's like MI for
universal health care as like a human
right yeah like we should have had that
decades ago the fact that it's tied to
employment is absurd so there are all of
these things that I disagree with Joe on
but I'm personally confident that if we
win we're going to be more open-minded
about the depths of the problems and
what we need to do about it because at
this point the problems are laid bare
for all to see now that it could be that
that optimism is misplaced
but that's truly what I believe like job
one beat Trump job to dig deep and
started working to solve these problems
if it turns out that I'm wrong in that
we're just scratching the surface then
I'll probably run again and say like
well [ __ ] this like you know like I'm
gonna try and like get the real things
going in another way I mean that's what
I tried to do this time but I came up
short and so then you know you have to
try and push forward in as positive and
practical way as you can and I'm I'm
optimistic that we're going to be open
to different measures than has
historically been the case because we're
dealing with a generational crisis and
everyone can see that
I pray that you're right Andrew and I
just don't see much sign in this town
that that is gonna be the case but I
certainly pray that you're right but you
just made some news I think you're
thinking you might run again if things
don't go well I'm already on the record
say I'm gonna run I'm gonna run for
office at some point I mean you can't
not but you can think about running for
president again yeah I would I mean you
know it's like I ran to solve the
problems the problem still exists I'd
actually have a much easier time with
another
than this last run because now you know
people have heard of me and do I mean
you just learned so much from the
process - is there anything you would is
there anything you would change in your
approach
well well first I'd replace the Zack guy
who who's just like a real wait on the
whole what one thing is you know I would
spend more time in DC trying to
familiarize people with with my vision
for the country and have them engage
with us intellectually what you just
said makes me sad crystal where you said
it's like while you're in that town and
you don't see like that reckoning that
sense of you know of a need for change
but one of the things I found in my
campaign was that if I spent time with
someone they would often go from who the
hell is this guy to like oh this person
seems sincere seems engage with the
issues seems like they genuinely want to
help and there were many many parts of
the establishment that I did not have
that opportunity with that I think I can
at least move a degree in the right
direction if I invest the time so that's
one thing I would do differently before
I was coming at it from the outsider
Lane because I was you know like new on
the scene and the rest of it and I want
to be still myself and true to the
vision while also trying to present to
folks that like I'm a reasonable leader
with the nation's interest at heart and
a patriot like I'm not here to castigate
or demonize anyone I just want to try
and move us forward because we're
decades behind the curve a lot of people
are suffering and we need to fix it and
to me this is not even just like us
versus them this is like just any kind
of enlightened self-interest it's like
look if you're rolling around in your
urban center it has to be clear to you
than ever that
life your very life is dependent upon
people risking their lives at every part
of the supply chain to try and get you
the chicken nuggets like you know like
like thinking that somehow if they get
more you're going to lose is total
[ __ ] like I just need to open
people's eyes yeah yeah I hear that and
I you know I think you're right like
optimism is the only choice right no
matter how many dispiriting things I see
coming across you know across my desk
every day here in this town and you know
I think there are a lot of reasons to be
discouraged if you believe in the values
that you believe in but there's no
choice other than optimism there's no
choice other than believing that you can
make that change because the only other
option is a complete like cynical
nihilism where you just disengage like
this [ __ ] yeah and frankly that stuff I
mean I I'm worried that that is gonna be
the decision of a lot of people
especially frankly young voters
working-class voters who just don't see
themselves represented or frankly even
treated with sort of respect by by the
party apparatus and so that is that is
one of my real fears is that that sort
of nihilism and cynicism will set in so
you're checking me reminding me that
optimism is really the only option oh
that's a legitimate fear and concern and
if someone says like hey these
institutions are morally bankrupt and
don't care about me I would say like I
completely understand why you feel that
way you might not even be entirely wrong
that's it that's the thing is I actually
agree I think they are morally bankrupt
I don't think that they really care
about you because from the beginning of
this crisis I mean again it's never been
more clear who did Trump bring in to
talk to all the corporate CEOs and the
banks who did you know Richie Neal who's
you know the head of an influential
committee here in on the hill who did he
want to call up like Hank Paulson and
Bob Rubin I mean it's just like the same
cast of characters and
clearly the ones who got their giveaways
and got their bowing got their own piece
of legislation handcrafted for them even
in a small business bailout right the
bigger guys get the concierge service
like it is morally bankrupt in my view
that's not like I finally something
impressive personally but that doesn't
mean it can't change and I think that's
the piece that you have to remain
optimistic about and you have to
recognize that like you know that
struggle doesn't happen like that it
doesn't happen overnight it's not easy
there are forces that are arrayed that
are that like the status quo that
benefit from the status quo and so you
can't get discouraged just because it
doesn't happen for you this time or
because the system doesn't all change at
once it takes a you know sustained
struggle is basically the path that you
have to choose I I'm concerned about the
negativity as well cuz I get it you know
it's like it's rational just like you
would be entirely rational for someone
to check out on politics because it
seems exhausting and mind-numbing and so
negative and they'd be like my life is
better if I'm just watching Tiger King
or you know something more diverting and
I endorse Tiger King only person in
America is not it's actually well done
documentary anyway so like and so anyone
who decides to check out is like I'm
sympathetic but we don't have a choice
like we have to engage with the systems
with politics and try and right the ship
and there there's no other way it's why
I ran you know I ran a non-profit for
better part of seven years and I
concluded I cannot solve the problem
unless I rewrite the rules the economy
from the top down and there was only one
way to realistically do that it was run
for president and win said okay let me
try that and while we did not win like I
did feel like we made massive progress
towards trying to implement a different
vision and I'm committed to that I
understand why people have given up but
we can't give up I mean like there's no
choice and one thing I admire a lot of
things about you crystal but you're also
like this supermom you've got like three
kids when you talk about being in DC in
that town like I get the sense you like
wake up at the crack of dawn or even
before dawn you like do these shows and
the rest of it and and then you're
you're like transporting yourself like
to like a totally different environment
and then becoming supermom at least this
is what I'm imagining and so like you're
a parent like I am it's like we can't
give up because you know our kids need
us to win that's that's it that's it
exactly and and also and not just our
kids like our kids let's be real have a
lot of advantages and are incredibly
lucky and privileged within this system
in society but like you know do I want
them to grow up in the kind of brutal
place that would pick like certain
people deserve to have it all and other
people deserve to basically like you
know deliver their sushi at 2:00 a.m.
for for scraps and not have health
insurance no I don't I don't think
that's good for anyone I don't think
it's obviously not good for the people
who are you know on the front lines
making low wages struggling every day
like it's obviously bad for them but I
think it's just corrosive to the soul of
the country I think it's corrosive and
destructive to everyone that is involved
with that I couldn't agree more I will
say that I look at my boys all the time
and I reflect on how differently they're
growing up then how I grew up and one of
my boys is autistic but neither of them
is particularly rugged I'll tell you
that like they you know I look at that
but it's like these kids are so lucky
would be the euphemism I guess where you
know it's like just a lot of these are
going on but I agree with you that that
even the winners lose in this
winner-take-all system that the and
you're seeing it to if you were to just
be driven by like mental health
indicators like you go to even elite
college campuses the kids are [ __ ]
miserable
you know like these are like the
offspring of the people that like
scratched and clawed their way to the
top and then what was the point you know
like that there's this inhumanity that
punishes us all and certainly it
punishes the people who are left in
material deprivation and early deaths
and poverty first and most immediately
but it is corruptive for everyone and
there are all of these material
incentives right now that distort our
behaviors in ways that make us just
worse people there are a lot of folks
that you know and you you you climb to
the top of one of these hierarchies and
then you've sacrificed so much for all
of this wealth and then you're like all
right I guess it must have been for the
money so this money must be the end-all
be-all you know that that's why I became
an [ __ ] that's exactly right and we
have we have to have and I don't know if
you're a fan of the economists thomas
piketty's done you know seminal works
yeah of course with his colleagues on
inequality and he has a new book out
that it's very long but I'm working on
it but one of the things that he lays
out is how throughout human history
societies have always had to construct
narratives and mythology around why some
people deserve this much and other
people deserve the scraps and we tend to
think that our mythology is like better
than you know if you're talking about
like feudal or kings and queens and all
of that
you mean our meritocracy mythology
exactly I mean we have to recognize we
have our own mythology and what it says
is like oh if you are that person that
scratches and claws your way like an
[ __ ] to the top and like crushes
everyone that you deserve those billions
of dollars billions upon billions that
you could never even spend in your
entire lifetime
Christel I worked hard you deserve it
all but these other people who you know
are struggling and scraping and who
our lower-income who are working-class
who's you know daily life is just very
difficult just to to make it all work
that that's what they deserve and so if
that is the mythology at the core of
your country like of course that leads
to treating some people like they are
modern-day lords and ladies who deserve
to have not only that money in what
comes with that but pout but to be the
people who hold power who make all the
important decisions right and to be sort
of treated as these demigods and then at
the other end of the spectrum because
you are not worthy of those things you
deserve to be treated less than human
and so I think that core mythology is
part of what you have really effectively
struck a blow against and that's why you
know I always tried to lift up your
campaign and what you were doing because
I think that core message is so
fundamentally important it is so radical
to say like every human being is worthy
and deserves dignity and deserves to be
treated fundamentally as a human being
as a human I can guarantee that just
about everyone at that Purdue processing
plan works a [ __ ] of a lot harder than I
do every single day you know hundred
percent yes absolutely
and hopefully that becomes apparent more
people I certainly felt like the
meritocracy [ __ ] really was like
this sinister
way to convince people it's like well if
you want it's because you worked so hard
and you know you were so talented and
that if someone's losing while they must
deserve it somehow and I just knew how
ridiculous that was on its face maybe in
part because I'm I grew up the child of
immigrants and my first real job after I
graduated from law school was set to
paint or did I mean I worked there paid
me more than my father was making and my
father had 69 patents and a PhD in
physics and I was like on what world
does my stupid corporate lawyer like
looking at this document for
errors like in what world is that more
valuable than my father literally
inventing [ __ ] like that that makes zero
sense and so to me I the the
ridiculousness of it became apparent
kind of early on but it's that mythology
that keeps so much of our people in line
ya know I mean so many there's another
great book utopia for realists I wish I
could remember the author's name Bregman
he's a friend yeah so he talks about
like [ __ ] jobs and how so many of
the jobs in our country and a lot of
developed countries are basically
[ __ ] like if they went away no one
would really notice and these tend to be
like the more highly paid white-collar
professions he gives this example I mean
if those management consultants like
like disappeared that we'd all be law
you know we would all be we would all
miss immediately all the CPAs like me
right are all hood all the youtubers
like me but um he gives this great
example of in Ireland there was like
this banking shut down and of course in
advance it was like oh my god what are
we gonna do it's gonna be a disaster we
can't lose the bankers and then it was
like no big deal people just figured it
out they actually used their local pubs
as like a sort of ad hoc way of lending
money and it was all totally fine and no
one really missed a beat so even at that
level it was like so many of these jobs
are just sort of puffed up [ __ ] you
know moving money around or moving
paperwork around or I don't know I
remember what she said
checking the errors and like a legal
briefing or whatever so much of it is
that and meanwhile the people who work
the hardest who actually make the
country run on a daily basis are the
people who are treated the shabbiest in
their work in their lives by our society
and I think that that's a crime yeah I
agree we have to try and restore the
dignity of each person and certainly my
seemingly radical give everyone money
like destruct some people as ridiculous
on its face because it's like all like
like how can that be but you know we
convinced millions of Americans this
crisis is convincing another millions of
Americans and I'm optimistic that we're
going to actually be able to humanize
this economy in the days to come in part
because we just don't have a choice yeah
yeah well I I'm gonna share in some of
your optimism I always so glad crystal
that's like my accomplishment of the day
and then you're gorgeous by the optimism
to millions and then we will take over
you know the government people know that
they have power I mean that's the thing
really is I want people to know that
they are not powerless observers that
they actually have agency and power in
this system and that maybe you talked
about one of the biggest lies that may
be one of the biggest lies that's fed to
people is that they they can't do
anything that they're hopeless that they
have to leave it to the people here no
you have power and agency you just have
to take it well you're living proof of
that crystal you were a 27 year old
woman who just ran for Congress not
having any business doing so and now now
you're a voice of reason and progress to
millions and an awesome role model and
I'm really glad to consider you a friend
well same here and you really admire
what you've done and I cannot wait to
see what comes next also crystal you're
working on anything you want to share
well the big thing is we would love for
people to check out rising on YouTube
just go to the hills YouTube channel and
hit subscribe smash subscribe click the
bell all that good stuff we love having
our viewers engage and just really
appreciate those people who have said
that the show we've been beating go to
them and check out crystal and Sawyer's
book the populist guide to 2020 a series
of essays about the race I show up in
some of them but there's a lot of wisdom
in this book I learned a lot by reading
it all the best of you and the family be
safe out there and thank you so much
they hated John for me as well I will do
that same to you and yours